(upbeat music)
(crowd cheers)
- So, get it out, get it out.
Get it out.
(crowd cheers)
- [Kelly] Thank you!
- Thank you so much.
(crowd cheers)
- I love that, I love that.
(audience member cheers)
Well we saw each other, was
it the People's Choice Awards?
- Yes.
- That's what, yeah.
My daughter, I know. I
wrote it in your card.
I dunno if you've read it yet.
She still talks about it.
And it was so cool, honestly,
to be there singing
along to all your songs.
Like, I love your music so much.
You're obviously a big influence for me
and a lot of female and male artists.
But my daughter, we were
just different generations,
and she was sitting there singing
along with me and dancing.
It was like the coolest moment.
- It was a really great moment.
It was just like a real
friendship connection moment
we were having.
Like, I'm eatin' her potato chips.
- She was talking about
ice cream which is, yep.
- She's gonna go out for
ice cream after the show
and cheering for her mom,
it was really lovely.
(Kelly laughs)
- I said if like she behaved,
I'd take her to get ice cream.
I was like, "Don't act crazy,
like when we go there."
But you were so nice to her.
And anyway, that was
just a really cool thing.
- I just love kids.
- Like, she literally got down
and was just like talking to
her just like a normal human.
Like, "Oh, what's your favorite flavor?"
Like, we're just hanging at
the People's Choice Awards.
My daughter was like, "Is this normal?"
(Shania laughs)
And I was like, "No, she's not normal.
She's really kind and cool."
I was like, "That's not normal."
- It was normal.
- Do you like events like that?
Do you like going,
I know you have to love
performing at them.
You kill at that.
- Well, the People Choice
element of it is really great.
- Yeah.
- I think that's always special
when the people are
involved with, you know,
making decisions on who they love
and who maybe they don't love.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, so it was nice in that way
and I got to, you know,
give a little Ryan Reynolds,
"You know who do you think you are?"
Which I thought was so fun.
- I like that, yeah.
- I thought the whole thing
was really just a very fun night.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I didn't know
you were gonna be sitting right beside me.
- I didn't either!
(Shania claps)
- It was like this great surprise.
- Yeah, I didn't know either.
So it was really, really cool.
And Carrie was at your table too. right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But she switched out.
She left before I got there.
(Shania laughs)
- She left, she left.
I know we all keep coming in and out
'cause we have to like
present or whatever,
perform or whatever.
But yeah, I was like,
"Oh, they put us all in one little area."
It was amazing.
Well, you're going back out on tour.
So what's different with this tour.
You've toured forever, right?
So what's different?
Last time I saw you was in
Vegas, which is incredible.
- [Shania] Oh well, thank you very much.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm going out on tour,
and it's gonna be a whole different show
than the Las Vegas show.
- Okay.
- So it's a whole other
thing, entirely different.
I'm gonna be adding in a lot of new songs
from the new album "Queen
of Me", which is so fun.
You know how that is,
adding new music, it just
freshens up everything.
Of course I'll do the classics too.
- Yeah.
- And just have a lot of fun out there.
So we start in March and, no, April.
- Yeah, so you have a
ton of quick changes.
People try and get me
to do this thing and-
(Kelly laughs)
- It's exhausting!
And I'm like, I'm running
back there, and I'm like-
Have you ever missed, one, a quick change?
Or have you ever like, just come out
and been like, well it
wasn't all put together?
(Kelly laughs)
- I didn't quite make it.
- Yeah.
- Well no, you know what?
I think that would be
such a fun game to do.
- Oh.
- You should, yeah.
- That should be a game on this show.
- No, I'm just-
- Quick Change Challenge is
our next game on this show.
- I know, I know.
(both laugh)
But it was like, "Okay."
You know, I want the audience to try out
the quick change challenge,
see how quickly you can get out
and back into another set of clothes.
I'm telling you'
- It's thought out.
Yeah, well I've hosted
the Billboard Awards
so that's the only time
I've done quick changes
that are like, yeah, it's like less than
three minutes sometimes or two minutes
and it's like super quick,
and it's like, I don't know.
- Something breaks.
You're like, "Just pin it!"
(both laugh)
- My God, there's lots of
swearing in a quick change.
- Yes, 100%.
No, we're really classy .
That never happens.
(audience laughs)
- It's a scream, swear fest!
- Yeah.
- You don't have to get
out there and stuff.
- So you've never like come out
on stage and just completely
'cause one time in my quick change,
they forgot to zip, do something.
They zipped me but didn't do the,
and I jumped around a lot on that tour
and so my dress almost came completely off
and I was commando so-
(group laughs)
[Shania Claps]
- So that would've gone real,
European beach real quick.
- Yeah, holy.
- Caught it, I caught it.
Has anything ever
happened to you like that?
- I've had things like that happen.
I've had other,
I think the biggest
mishap I've had on stage,
well actually the biggest
mishap I've had on stage
with my horse.
- Oh, no.
- One time, yeah.
My horse, I was on
stage, drops a big poop.
(Kelly laughs)
And I mean, it's big and
it's steamy and it's stinky,
you know.
(Kelly sighs)
I mean, not for me.
I love the smell of horse poop.
(Kelly laughs)
Everything I own smells like horse poop.
But it was just really awkward, you know?
And so I decided to say,
"Well, (bleep) happens."
(group laughs)
(crowd cheers)
- I actually would've loved
that, being at that show.
Oh my gosh.
We are back with Shania Twain, everybody.
(crowd cheers)
- Her new album is called "Queen of Me".
It drops tomorrow.
I wanna show the new
album, the single covers.
'Cause y'all, I, at no point in my life
will ever look like this.
(Kelly laughs)
Like, I just want to, like what?
Like-
(audience cheers)
- [Shania] Yeah.
- I honestly wish we would've prepared
to have me on one of my horses.
Like, and how just the juxtaposition,
(Kelly laughs)
the difference, like, I love this though
because you are one of those
women, especially for me,
like I just think growing
up it was like in the South,
you always had to be, you know,
turtleneck and skirt down
here, and it was like,
I think there's nothing wrong
with like loving your body,
especially when you've been given that.
And then, and then also
like, that's your own body,
that's your own sexuality,
that's your own sensuality,
all of it.
I think it's so-
I think it's beautiful,
and I think it's amazing
that you are comfortable and you love it.
It looks like you
and it looks like the word "free".
Like whenever I saw it, I was
like, "Oh, she looks free."
- I think it's just very important
to be comfortable in our own skin.
I'm not an exhibitionist
and, you know, and I don't-
- I kind of am.
- Are you?
(group laughs)
How do you?
You walk around the house
with that (indistint)?
- Totally.
- [Shania] Really?
- 100%.
- Good for you!
- I know, it's not like with my kids
hanging out like on the couch or anything,
but like, yeah, no,
I don't have a problem with nudity, yeah.
- See I always did and I never, yeah.
I'm one of these people that never enjoyed
looking in the mirror with the lights on.
And now, you know,
(Kelly laughs)
I'm 57, I've been in menopause for years.
I'm like, "Okay, if I don't learn to love
what I'm looking at in the mirror now,
I'm gonna hate myself tomorrow."
If I don't look at myself today
I'm gonna hate myself tomorrow
because it's just getting, you know,
saggier, lumpier, whatever it is.
- [Kelly] Gravity.
- Yeah, gravity.
- It's a wonderful thing.
(audience laughs)
- So I said, "No, no, I'm
gonna start right now."
So I did that photo shoot.
I did a lot of nude photos.
I forced myself into the, you know,
under the lights, in front of the cameras
with the crew there.
- Yeah.
- Taking these pictures,
I'm marking this day
as this is the best I'm going
to look any way forever.
So I might as well own that and enjoy it
while I've got whatever that is at 57.
(crowd cheers)
- I also think it's weird
that like from a young age,
I don't get it.
My mother doesn't get it either.
She's very different from me.
But like, I think it's weird
how we look at the human body.
I think it's strange how we
think of it as like this,
you know, thing you should cover up
when it's like such a beautiful
thing, like male or female.
Like it's a beautiful thing.
And there's a way to do it.
in like a classy, tasteful
way of like celebrating.
Like whatever you believe in,
God, whatever you believe in,
like this is the one
being that looks like this
and celebrate that.
- Well this is who you are.
This is who I am.
- Yeah.
- And so when I do look
in the mirror, I'm like,
"Well, this is the 57 year
old me, and that's all right."
- First of all, you just said it again.
Can we just-
I just need you to see the pictures.
Yeah, you know where I'm going.
It's like, this is not
a 57 year old woman.
(group laughs)
This is not, this is just,
put 'em up, yep.
Nope, nope!
(audience cheers)
Girl, there's a reason
why God did not allow me
to look like that.
(Kelly laughs)
I would just walk around naked everywhere.
Anyway, what's the meaning
behind the name of the album
"The Queen of Me"?
- Okay, so "Queen of Me"
really does summarize
all of that sense of personal identity,
ownership of your identity.
Saying, "Listen, I drive my own bus.
I'm the boss of me.
I am the queen of me.
I'm not the boss of anyone else.
I'm the boss of myself."
And that means that I take responsibility
for my decision making.
For if I, you know, if
I'm in a down spirit,
it's up to me to pick myself up.
- Yeah.
- So I start getting into my songwriting.
'Cause that's what I do when I get bored
or when I'm too isolated.
- Me too.
- And I, right?
- Yeah, that's where I work it out.
- Personally, that's where
you work it out, it's therapy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I'm thinking,
"Okay, I'm gonna just write
myself into a better spirit."
- That's beautiful.
- I'm gonna write songs
that make me wanna dance
and make me feel happy.
(audience cheers)
- Yeah.
You have a song I wanna talk about.
It's called "Inhale, Exhale".
- Yeah.
- What's that about?
What a cool title.
What a cool vibe, yeah.
- "Inhale, Exhale".
I affectionately call the song "Air".
With everyone suffering from, you know,
the Covid is such a respiratory, you know,
infection that really can take
your life very, very quickly.
I had a bad bout with it.
I won't go into it,
but when I was released from the hospital,
the first thing I did was
write down a list of things
that air gives us.
Obviously life.
- Yeah.
- But I'm thinking,
"Okay, cheer yourself up.
What does air give us
that is very celebratory?"
So I'm thinking, champagne
bubbles, balloons, you know-
- I love where your brain went.
(Kelly laughs)
- Sailing though, too.
It's like, you know,
with the air we can sail,
we can sail, we can
fly, we can fly a kite.
We have all these lovely
things to celebrate about air.
And of course, like I said,
you know, life itself.
So I wrote the song, what are you gonna do
without that air, you know?
"Inhale, Exhale".
So that's the most
inspired song on the album.
- Yeah, I love that though,
when it comes from real life
and then you come up with this
completely different concept
off of that one moment.
- Well, because I didn't
wanna look back on it.
I'm like, "Okay, whew, I'm through it.
Write a happy song about
surviving it and celebrate."
- I love that you do that.
We are so different.
So I'm gonna try what you do.
I usually write when I'm
sad, and I get it out.
I've never written to become happy,
which is maybe the larger issue.
(Shania laughs)
I'm finding in this interview.
But that's a very clever
thing to use your gift for,
like to write, to be happy.
Usually I'm writing just to get it out.
I guess I become happy
after getting it out,
but like I've never had
the mentality of that.
Anyway, it's cool.
- No, but it's a great fit.
Song writing is venting, of course.
That's a great place to vent writing.
- Yeah.
- [Shania] You know, but
I mean, even writing-
- [Kelly] Welcome to my albums.
(group laughs)
- But writing songs, I do
it as an exercise also.
And to challenge myself.
So I, of course, I write lots of songs
that are very melancholy, very dark.
If I'm really upset and mad,
I put it all in the song.
- Yeah.
- But then I go back to it later,
and I turn it around, just
like a writing exercise.
I just turn it around and now
I make it just like you would
if putting a song in first-person
or third-person or whatever.
- You find the light in it.
Yeah, that's cool.
- [Shania] Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Finding the upside of everything.
- I know.
So it can be difficult,
but I hear that you're pretty competitive.
How about a game after the break?
- Oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] Are you down?
- [Shania] I'm up, I'm
down, I'm up, I'm up for it.
- Okay, I just wanna, I'm
up and I'm down for it.
(both laugh)
I just wanna beat you at this game.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience claps)